hi are you ready Adam and James play
video game video game hey yo games I
don't know jamesburg video games yeah
hello and welcome to Adam and James play
video games we are once again in GTA 5
this is because we love this game I am
indeed Adam as always well good driving
there us and I enjoyed by Jesus aguado
would have time to crush there fella
there's an awkward time to arrive at our
location while you're doing your intro
right we'll jump out oh no we won't oh
you dog fallen off and there's blood
everywhere starters we mean to go on
right we're going to get changed we were
in biker gear I'm in Seoul fifties
attire what have you gone for ladies
choice by your mother by looks a bit
right and we will go catch it now what
are we dressing for here if we got
something lying we Shh we should be
dressing for halloween as that's what's
coming up you actually just buy
something random to try and scare the
other person oh yes bill I've already
I've already got the right thing in mind
without doubt I'm gonna wait outside
then I'll see you scares who before come
for the same thing oh I love it man i
love it i hope we don't map minted right
when he masks just a couple of guys
hanging out in a car deke boson so we've
gone from assless chaps to this don't
judge us man don't judges in our bright
pink car with neons no man pants should
we not tell each other again yeah all
right let's see what we can come up with
so we're going for halloween aren't we
awesome things gonna freak out each
other yeah I found you I found you it
cost me a lot I'm just gonna stand
behind you with it
oh my god how come it happened so much
we gotta say mother gave me really oh my
god we really know each other that is
Ricky it isn't it right there's mine
yeah your baby this is getting really
disturbing so we have our outfits for
Halloween I can't get over that
masculine uary we need something to do
now so last time we played the odd game
which was jump off a bridge and splat on
the floor but today it's my choice my
choice is go as high as we can in a
helicopter and try and parachute and
land on the moving train are you up for
this challenge Jim's oh wow definitely
that sounds difficult I can't wait wow
you're going to love it my right hand is
going to be all jumping out of a plane
and the left hand is going to be the
train and this is what we've got to do
James we've got to land on the plane
like this right I think we need
different outfits so we can actually
tell each other apart look if I can get
on board with that yeah no problem I'll
go put on my lips I crashed no notice
don't worry oh I'm back in my flat cap
I'm a happy man you in any way no you
wait let me know you're now going leave
it on the edge sitting on the edge right
waits it strange that law yes let's look
for the train and then we can start to
again altitude and attempt to land on it
but first we must find the train this
may take a while well if I shoot the
track of it that may make it spawn
closer I'm talking or 20 here this is
that it would it's like I did would do
it all right you give me a countdown and
I will suck first myself he are gonna be
the first person to land on the train
down there using your mission impossible
skills Ethan Hunt over to you jump
mother flipper
off dent dead dead dead dead it did good
I can't help it I'm coming as well
dinner you get in you gonna do you might
allow to use my parachute haha you
missed it I'm totally missed it dude I'm
on the ground I'm not fast enough it's
getting away no stop oh god damn it it
does not look like you are there someone
you first I'll get for you there you go
ah helicopters ear they SAT rain here's
the train train was gonna go straight
for it then jump I've gone did done dirt
off this is it's gonna be somebody's I'm
gonna kill em on the ground I was
terrible until I went into the side of
the bridge and I'm now dead god this is
very dark isn't it I guess at its nature
of nighttime Oh turned out the light
okay mission impossible tick three over
to you Joe Dirt oh that's casualty haha
alright I'm just gonna go for it good
luck sir you want mere i'm headed
straight for it i'm gonna try to get a
bit head of it so that I've got time
once I parachute oh I think I think I'm
gonna run out yeah right I'm parachuting
I parachute is open I'm gonna try and
quit it oh that brush Dale britches away
don't stirred I don't know where I'm
going oh crap what am I going where is
it oh come on come on train speed up
speed up I need it right here we go i
think i might have this dun dun dun dun
Oh
a fella oh so close so close oh I all
I'm on it from dead my lumia how'd I do
my [ __ ] in the air if I I'm still
falling I'm still falling I've made it I
made it you've got strain land on it
dude we someone has to to succeed before
we can move on okay and to make it more
like a film she like I'm closer to you
of the front yeah okay oh crap in the
head I'm NT unclothed here I'm so sorry
it was for added effect so this is our
final attempt we are in a helicopter
traveling it I don't know 10,000 feet I
don't know whatever means our task is to
jump up to this helicopter with our
parachute and land on that train down
there I'm getting vertigo with this
camera angle I'm just gonna go for it if
you don't mind yeah let's both go for it
she looks away hey I'm going for the
slow and steady approach is it up near
is because I'm so far ahead yeah we were
a bit far ahead sorry I'm heading for it
now I've got trying time this right come
on I'm running out of time I've got him
after too much oh come on I did it I'm
on the train I'm just sitting on the
train oh no no I've got a great view of
you knocked me off at noon yeah he's
just face-planted into the side of this
one linea he didn't say how I landed
with muttered i used my face to stop
right remember yes to get to the front
of the Train front of the Train using
your running skills buckle yeah made it
I've made it to the front of the tree
come and join me dude right we need some
sort of celebration here ah [ __ ] me up
man well I thought it was Mission
Impossible we did it oh oh get back on
get back on get my gun I'm get aside or
died I died oh god it's sort of
painstaking but we did it mission
impossible part 2 as I'm the one who
died and you stayed on I'll try and pick
you up using a helicopter ah right the
coppers are on me now as well this
relapse that's the detention there we go
up mission impossible don't dead dead
dead dead don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't gen time to save your are
you ready to be saved where are you oh
yeah can you save me I'm right in the
middle on the red bit hi are you ready
good Oh your propellers propelled me
literally oh that's one of the coolest
things I've ever seen there's a tunnel
coming up you gotta load up in a
superman jump hahaha ok I've got so
little time and it's going to ride a
corner as well go on lad good that note
are you watching oh good you look like
you're ahead but you are you all right
I'm a little bit ahead i'm a little bit
ahead oh no I'm running out time over
now time come on drain hurry up come on
man these trainees to hurry up run to
the back and one mission impossible you
out of it uh actually don't fit in this
tunnel I don't feet and don't like
oh right I'll get you at the other side
of the door open Oh sec while stressful
I love it all right you straddled will
try landing on her on a train before it
enters a tunnel I'm coming out of the
tunnel now eternal heading out of the
tunnel and going straight under a bridge
I got under the bridge all right I can
touch you some come on oh come on now
off the train I couldn't figure out how
to duck a panicked all right here we go
you ready for this bump bump bump bump
can I get my carcass to hit the train
did it it back up a bit back up a bit
back up a bit but I'm on the tray if I
don't get in did you get it let me give
it get it get it get it get it the
tunnel Oh are we still alive let me let
me in I've just down here yeah come on
hover over what the hell your name is
all dis your bum hey I'll trade you
trade dear trick races realtor trivia Oh
missed it oh I'm on it Oh missed it
afrikaanse it hit the end of the dream
ah no ah so freaking close
right so--okay you followed the front of
the train and I'll trying to plop into
you I'm just getting in my helicopter
hat no pressure but I've jumped out haha
West right I want to just take it off
all right the helicopter the trains
coming towards me so can you see me I
think so I'm gonna do this without
parachute I thanks for the warning there
are we out of debt what's going on where
are you just just stood right down here
middle of world where are they were in
the road I'm gonna do it without the
trends behind you is it I'm in what we
do it right oh let's just Paris you on
the trail again I'll do see ya once
train track noise that [ __ ] boy you
missed it get up get up on him you don't
see it yeah I noticed I'm gonna jump in
anywhere jump it jump it oh no i've been
taken out stand up come on come on oh
it's gone past fine if you want to try
again try again i'm right yeah really
all right there stepping drown just to
see it's much our this guy could try
again there you go you could dragon took
from india ok do for me five feet away
will be ring fashion hahahahahaha is it
girl forgot sick big Nick the trailer
Gator allows women hahahahaha
over higher this time it's well add to
jump back from five feet away I must be
edit this time go Oh parachute I forgot
about the pirate ship bit I'm on are you
right all right I'm falling down but I'm
on I'll be idea hum bhi ing Adam now
there's a suit now see if you can cut my
head off yeah Ricky month didn't stir
dead dead dead dead dead freaking day
they're dead dead duck duh doug is it
break up you duck oh I'm all right i'm
ok i'm not very tall they're cut your
head off hi helicopter I have a camper
you'd really kill me dead yeah I'm a
little bit dead oh we're gonna lose it
we're gonna lose it we're not Oh next
time on GTA adventures we will be doing
more challenges so if you've got any
ideas for one please letters north right
in the comments below and we will try
and act on it next time here's the pilot
their tip equip the pilot where's the
fire let's gone haha jump on to I'm
gonna kill myself in midair [ __ ] up so
this is me a damage as play video games
we'll see you very soon please press
like and subscribe goodbye my friend
bye-bye